[MUSIC]
There are still strange phenomena in the world that cannot be explained by science.
It's good to have those who keep fighting day by day, shining a ray of light on such a fundamental
sarcasm.
It
's about the reward, but which course should I take to exorcise?
The trial course is 20%
serious d coaster 50% serious c change and 99%
reduction  I promise
you that
amazing 0 is something like carbon trioxide, so
is it dependent?  Matattera p Oh, I'll take care of it based on my history
[music]
Come on, I'm Taro, the man who eats the stained
poop.  It's better j It's
shady Well, what about being haunted by a ghost?
It should be back to normal all the time
Don't worry about your face, yeah Sidewalk You said
you started having dreams every night after you tested your courage last week It's
already scary and creepy
Tehara-sensei That building
That's an amazing touch of home
It's been a long time after a long time,
oh, oh, oh, ah, I'm going to make a rower here, oh, yeah
yeah yeah yeah, it's amazing from there, but if this is the difference, it will be a hanger
9 yesterday and it will be destroyed yesterday.
Is there a female ghost everywhere? It's
pattern 3. I love it. My voice is boiling
. Raw is an evil spirit.
Let's deal with
agricultural products early, let's leave because that's what people say Let's go cute  It's said that there's a provenance,
you 6 believe me, hit me,
goo.
Hey, it's
definitely a fake Oh
, because of you
par
Let's break through Kinjo with my curse
haha
nao
I think it'll come out first
70 It
's a 0 special move that violently spews out salt
It's sold at supermarkets  Isn't it
good to
eat?  Will you come soon?
Aiya, seriously, seriously, there's an evil spirit.I'm
waiting for the customers and the evil spirits, so do
n't hurry
up.I'm begging you
.
His name is Shigeo Kageyama, commonly known as
Moubun, he is a real psychic and a miracle worker, and he is
the main character of this story
.  Beyond my claws
hao
me
[music]
ana
ani
ha The scene I was looking for yeah yeah yeah
Future
[music]
ni
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
[music]
dj
me
[music]
daaaaaaaaaa
A little off a
Mercer I wonder if there really are evil spirits
?  Are you dissatisfied or not? It's
just that you were a really low-class guy just
now.  Is it true?
I don't really understand the meaning of "I can put a burger" First of all, that's because you don't have enough
training.  It might be killing two birds with one stone,
but if you misuse your too much power, you'll destroy yourself.
You're teaching me how to control my powers so that I don't have to. You
promised me you would
n't use your psychic powers on people,
tan.
Is
n't shigeo also in puberty?
If you have any troubles, tell me, I'll
give you advice even if you
tell me, thank you.
[music]
What happens to the 9 answers when you're a princess
Then Kageyama oi kore I
don't know If you don't understand this, there's only Tachiyama left
Oh, I'm sorry it was yesterday, but
will you come to the station right away?
It's a well-
known haunted spot
now.P was originally closed in the tunnels in September, but many years have passed, but bad rumors still persist
.
The eaves are also angry
This is the ultimate answer.It's
after the farmland while driving
in groups.I'm talking about 30 years ago.
In preparation for the concentrated
popularity,
come
on, let's take a look at
one of them.
I heard that you're coming for lunch, and you're injured, so
I bought a CD and went home
However, I follow my voice thinking that I'm studying, but the
finals are
amazing.That tunnel looks pretty dangerous.
was real  You know,
if an ordinary person pissed off the example in
there
, yeah  So I'll leave the support to the regular head Yes, the
room looks cool
Sounds like it's a tradition in the middle of the day Master, can't you feel something?  Hey,
stuffy nose
has something to
do with it When you get to my level, you can't feel anything, you can't feel it
Alien
18 No,
there's more than that.
That's why I made you cry
[music] It's
not that bad If it wasn't for Japanese I wonder if it wouldn't have been there
anyway  You must have been surprised to think it was an
evil spirit Don't you practice in a place like this
?  Riyadh center of this spiritual message
[music] It's on
sale Yes,
I made it around that time.
In fact,
the moment I faced this miracle,
I didn't have
it.
But it's not a big deal, so I'm going to leave it there after
all
.
Green
We were just melting down the guys who came here under the order
of Uoichi.
I just thought it was
Orito Aichi, and when I went home, ah,
wood by 5 doors, Isobe Tarimin, left and bluffed like
that.
Kansai
I'll take a look before that.
Rione Yes, it's been ricined here
It's the leader.
Great world
Well,
[music]
Pop, it's already a child
, isn't it?
That's right.
Telephone uj With this, I Tajima, a shop that says that I can go to heaven with just my heart
.
The prime minister,
why didn't you do
anything?  Okay okay
yes
[music]
If you're going to add charco, I'll keep it up to two
Okay,
cog
[music]
Let's make it something that suddenly appeared It's King Midas' miso radio collection
Bob, who had doubts about the peaceful blue spring  Where is the goal of heading to the women's garden
? Which is tomorrow?